Sunday in Bogota is a day of rest and relaxation...
...and the best place to do it is La Candelaria.
It's the oldest neighborhood in Bogota built in 1580...
...and it's a perfect blend of history and charm.
La Candelaria has everything that I love:...
...narrow cobblestone streets, colorful cafes...
...and lots of peaceful squares.
One of my favorites is Plaza del Chorro de Quevedo,...
...smaller than the main Plaza de Bolivar...
...and teeming with street art.
All of the handicraft shops are worth a visit and the churches.
And you've got to take a lunch break...
...to try the most popular dish in this Colombian capital city,...
...ajia, a thick, hearty soup typically made with chicken,...
...potatoes, corn and herbs.
With an average temperature of 58 degrees,...
...soups are always on the menu in Bogota.
Around every corner in La Candelaria,...
...you will discover something magical.
This is Plaza de Bolivar.
Every square you visit around the world has its own character...
...and Plaza de Bolivar is full of little moments.
You've got people selling drinks,...
...kids running with the pigeons, llamas walking around...
...and this beautiful backdrop of the cathedral.
La Candelaria inspires a sense of calm,...
...a low-key, lovely neighborhood...
...where Sundays and every day just seem right.